bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
reporteros gracias por estar con
nosotros comenzamos seis años después de
los atentados del 13 de noviembre en
parís y en sant denim considerado los
más mortíferos en francia- y cometidos
por atacantes suicidas islamistas
comenzó en septiembre el juicio
histórico contra los acusados soy uno de
los testigos y víctima de esa fatídica
noche cuenta lo ocurrido danielsen y era
periodista del diario le monde y vecino
de la sala de conciertos del bataclán
esa noche estaba en su casa y cuando
comenzó a escuchar las detonaciones
decidió grabar con su teléfono desde su
ventana y luego desde la calle donde
recibió un disparo mientras intentaba
ayudar a los heridos esa grabación que
hizo el periodista es la única que
existe sobre este atentado precisamente
ese vídeo ayudó a la reconstrucción de
lo ocurrido en imágenes animadas el
siguiente reportaje fue escrito y
producido por mustafa que sus esto es la
historia
[Música]
y éstos
muchas cosas
[Música]
hace unos años hice un viaje a jerusalén
en memoria de mis padres y mis abuelos
recuerdo que la ciudad vieja estaba
bañada en una hermosa luz salvaje
[Música]
desde el mirador podía mirar el muro de
las lamentaciones y la explanada de las
lolitas
ese cruce de religiones como lo cuentan
los días sin mucha convicción seguir la
costumbre pero no sabía qué escribir
así que de forma algo provocativa
escribí mi número de teléfono
[Música]
y si dios existe me llamará me dije
y
luego puse un pedazo de papel en las
grietas del muro por supuesto nunca
nadie me llamó
el 13 de noviembre de 2015 fui a la vez
observador rescatista víctima y
sobreviviente
me gusta pensar que tal vez él estaba
pensando en mí aquella noche
[Música]
no
terminamos nuestra tarde de audiencias
escuchando al señor daniels en su mundo
buenas noches mi señor usted es
periodista de le monde usted mismo fue
víctima de los atentados del 13 de
noviembre de 2015 en el bataclán y si tú
quieres yo sí y fue usted quien grabó la
huida de los espectadores del batán
grande
plutón fue fotógrafo durante mucho
tiempo tengo mi acreditación como
periodista desde 1977 y ahora soy un
periodista honorario como se dice
lo hace por los mejores períodos sin
arrepentimientos ni remordimientos fue
estupendo duelos mejores periódicos le
mataban liberación de mont por supuesto
que si teníamos todas las puertas
creo que era el momento de pasar la
página y coincidió con este evento
absolutamente trágico pero en cualquier
caso hubo una secuencia de eventos que
me llevó a hacer todo esto el 13 de
noviembre de 2015 fue una casualidad
entré en la historia por casualidad
[Música]
el 13 de noviembre tenía que ir a la
mesón de la radio a escuchar un
concierto de música cinematográfica
porque me gusta mucho luego por alguna
razón cambie de idea y volvía a casa
para trabajar y también para descansar
era un viernes un viernes 13 sara mi
esposa no estaba en casa la había
regresado a budapest yo estaba solo en
parís
había una película de sanyo anglac que
quería ver era una historia sobre un
policía arrepentido
y no le estaba poniendo mucha atención
[Aplausos]
y a las 9 40 pm hoy lo que parecían
disparos o petardos
cuando oí esos ruidos pensé que venían
de la película
al cabo de un rato me di cuenta de que
los disparos eran mucho más fuertes que
en una película y de que había muchos
disparos ráfagas
y entonces me di cuenta de que estaba
ocurriendo en la calle y no en la
pantalla
voy a abrir la ventana para ver
fue entonces cuando vi cogía disparos y
vi gente huyendo gritando y fue entonces
cuando me dije algo muy grave está
pasando
y por reflejo periodístico tome fondos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
al principio pensé que era un ajuste de
cuentas en el bataclán que un tipo había
sacado una pistola ha empezado a
disparar y todos habían huido
aterrorizados
cuando vi lo que era same al periódico
sólo tenía el número de b no abarca uno
de los redactores jefes de lemont y le
dije estoy en casa está pasando algo muy
grave en el bataclán
él me dijo ya ha habido varios tiroteos
en parís me dije voy a grabar
[Aplausos]
es crispar
mismas
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hola
yo
[Música]
y eso lo que vi era terrible nunca había
visto eso era la primera vez que veía
algo así era extremo cuando entiendes
que es muy grave tienes esta ilusión de
protección estás detrás de una pantalla
y te sientes protegido en un momento
dado estaba en la ventana y no pasaba
nada veía gente tendida frente a la
puerta de bataclán con los teléfonos que
brillaban
probablemente eran personas heridas
tratando de llamar a personas muertas
que sacaron sus teléfonos por reflejo
pero no había más disparos no había más
gritos y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
aunque no sabía lo que pasaba adentro
había resistencia había tipo que veía
que se hacían matar
así que se abre la ventana y decidió
andar
[Música]
agarre el cargador del celular me puse
los zapatos sin amarrar los estaba en
camisa
[Música]
hace las cosas sin pensarlo vas a ayudar
a gente que está en la peor de las
situaciones herida agonizando me parecía
obvio
ha aparecido un puma
y la cuidamos
y entonces con cuidado abrí la puerta me
asomé un poco para ver me fui con
cuidado no salía el medio de la calle y
era lo mismo no había más disparos nada
un silencio terrible
[Música]
la mayoría de los cuerpos estaban frente
a la puerta de el bataclán solo había
alguien con una camisa roja a unos 10
metros más o menos en la acera
con mucho cuidado
me incliné sobre él y vi que estaba vivo
y entonces con otro tipo que estaba en
medio de la calle no sé qué hacía era y
era surrealista porque él estaba de pie
en medio de la calle
así que lo jalamos para meterlo en el
pasillo para que no quedara expuesto en
caso de que volvieran a disparar y el
tipo de negro desapareció
entonces jalea mate o un poco más
alrededor de un metro para poder cerrar
esa puerta
con especial roja pelvis como estaba
tranquilo llame a benoit para explicarle
lo que pasaba lo que estaba viendo dice
decenas de cuerpos personas que habían
oído por la puerta por decenas o incluso
cientos pero hay muertos le dije
y entonces sentí una quemadura intensa
en mi brazo y el teléfono cayó al suelo
en el pasillo
no sé por qué perdí mis zapatos y me di
cuenta de que me habían disparado y la
sangre corría
[Música]
estaba consciente pero aún así como
cuando uno recibe un golpe estaba
agitado
y me dije si me caigo estoy muerto
si me mantengo de pie es que estoy vivo
después benoit me dijo que había
esperado siete minutos creo antes de que
yo tomara el teléfono para decirle que
estaba vivo
pero en el momento uno piensa en
salvarse el pellejo se dice estoy muy
herido me dispararon tengo que llegar al
hospital y comió
como estaba perdiendo tanta sangre me
quité la camisa y me hizo un torniquete
uno hace lo que puede con los dientes
con la otra mano se las arregla y me
dije voy a llamar a mis vecinos
bruno y este el que viven en el cuarto
piso para que vengan a ayudarme
[Música]
y nos hicimos la promesa de que nos
iríamos antes de la fecha del
aniversario uno solo quiere seguir
adelante que su vida no gire solo en
torno a esto
para bruno era muy difícil me decía que
no podía haber más esa calle y creo que
incluso hoy cuando volvemos prefiere
evitarlas
él ve cosas que yo no veo no me muertos
de cercano y las imágenes que lo
impactaron
y
la imagen que más me persigue es la de
un hombre corriendo y la parte trasera
de su cabeza explota
durante las primeras semanas cada vez
que pasaba por la calle volvía a ver eso
aquí no se lo conté a nadie
y creo que eso es lo que quería lo que
buscaba al mudarnos al extranjero nunca
lo olvidaré pero está dejando de ser un
trauma para convertirse en un recuerdo
[Música]
[Risas]
este viernes 13 me había tomado el día
libre para pasar un rato con que
teníamos una salida estuvimos en el
museo picasso esa mañana
elsa nuestra hija mayor estaba en clase
de cocina con la escuela volvía el
sábado
[Música]
estábamos viendo el partido en
televisión el partido en el stand de
france todo el mundo lo recuerda
[Aplausos]
y entonces un estallido durante el
partido de fútbol una explosión
escuchamos un boom y luego incluso vimos
a los comentaristas interrumpirse entre
ellos y preguntarse qué estaba pasando
yo pensé que un proyector se había
dañado
el partido siguió francia notó y en un
momento dado oímos un ruido que parecía
un martillo para romper asfalto
y luego al instante oímos a la gente
gritar
así que nos apresuramos a acercarnos a
la ventana para ver qué pasaba
[Aplausos]
hola
[Música]
ya no
no
bien
[Música]
inmediatamente pensé en los hermanos
quay y en charlie hebdo y pensé que era
otro atentado
[Música]
charly esto está a tres calles de
distancia nos dimos cuenta de que era un
atentado para mí era como una escena de
película la gente corriendo bajo el
fuego de las ametralladoras mi hijo
estaba durmiendo en su habitación
lemos tenía cinco años en ese momento no
quería que viera eso
[Música]
así que llamó a la policía y me dicen
señora no podemos ayudarla y yo digo no
no pero hay un tiroteo en el bataclán
señora hay tiroteos por todo parís y hay
un tiroteo en un papel clave en el
bataclán está seguro vivo cerca los veo
la gente está corriendo en la calle y
entonces le oigo decir tiros en el batán
gran fuego y me digo no no están alcance
no teníamos ni idea de la magnitud de la
situación interior que son y si
inmediatamente sonó mi teléfono y era
véronique la vecina del piso de abajo
que me dijo no sé qué está pasando puedo
subir a su casa así que espere a que
verón y que subiera
[Música]
durante este tiempo estuvimos congelados
en frente al televisor había banners en
la pantalla anunciando los atentados
estaba aturdido estaba de pie inmóvil no
sabía qué estaba pasando estaba tieso
como una tabla con sobresalte y está el
contexto abran estoy herido pregunté
tienes es daniel estoy herido vengan a
abrir y vuelvo y digo [__] danielle
estado bajo está herido
baje no lo pensé seguí mis instintos
y en ese momento me dio miedo porque era
un contacto directo con el exterior era
una situación bastante angustiosa y
estaba muerto de miedo no me habría
puesto en peligro si no me hubieran
llamado
[Música]
cuando llegué vi a danielle de pie
sosteniendo su brazo y ya sus pies un
hombre que estaba boca abajo en un baño
de sangre había sangre por todas partes
[Música]
le dije a daniel entra schubert ascensor
sube al cuarto piso allá hasta en estelí
véronique
y entonces me di la vuelta y veo que
perón y que también está ahí no sé por
qué me siguió no me lo esperaba
[Música]
yo vivía en el pasaje desde hace al
menos 15 años
no conocía muy bien a mis vecinos
realmente nos conocimos durante esa
noche en extrañas circunstancias
[Música]
me costaba hablar de el bataclán hablaba
de otras cosas pero no de patatas
de alguna manera en efecto no
físicamente pero tuvo un impacto en mi
vida
[Música]
para mí vivir en parís se volvió
complicado
[Música]
durante dos años aunque tenía apoyo
psicológico tenía que volver a casa
antes de que anocheciera
la mongol
tenía miedo de estar en la calle por la
noche
[Música]
y el hecho de que se me reconociera como
víctima fue importante para mi
reconstrucción
[Música]
no debía estar ahí en absoluto unos
horas antes estaba en el extranjero y no
debía volver a casa
[Música]
llevaba dos meses y medio rodando en
marruecos
eso incidió
era una serie de televisión sobre
geopolítica y espionaje industrial
en esa serie había mucha sangre falsa
mucho maquillaje efectos especiales
personas heridas
sí
y fue un rodaje que en cierta manera me
preparó para lo que pasó en el bataclán
[Música]
teníamos que terminar el rodaje
alrededor del 17 de noviembre
así que tenía que estar en marruecos en
ese momento y la suerte quiso que
volviera el día 13 una hora antes de lo
sucedido en el bataclán
y fue muy sorprendente porque después
llegué al bataclana y volvió a ver
exactamente lo mismo y ya no era falso
había algo un poco raro en cuanto a que
de alguna manera mi cerebro aceptaba lo
que veía
la gente
ah
aceptaba lo que estaba viendo porque ya
lo había visto antes
[Música]
confiada ideal al mismo
cuando llegue a la casa a las 8 8 y 30
y estaba en la cama y me dije me voy a
dormir mañana aprovechar el día ahora
estoy cansada voy a dormir
y luego empecé a oír un ruido en la
calle como se oye normalmente pero pensé
esto está raro
esta salida de conciertos no es como las
de siempre
me levanté y fui a la cocina para ver
qué pasaba en la calle fue entonces
cuando empecé a oír gritos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y lo que pasó en ese momento es que
entendíamos lo que estaba pasando y no
entendíamos nada al mismo tiempo
[Música]
y terminé acurrucada para protegerme sin
saber lo que realmente ocurría fuera
termine así protegiendo vi y oí la voz
de bruno arriba así que lo llamé
[Música]
más refinado en la acción entra en
acción con bruno cuando bajamos
a partir de ese momento la sensación que
tuvo fue que ya no era yo
y
sentí que mi cabeza se centraba en una
sola cosa ayudar a los que sufrían
cuando baje había sangre por todas
partes
[Música]
recuerdo haber pensado este hombre no
puede perder tanta sangre un hombre no
tiene tanta sangre así imposible
[Música]
así que ambos subieron y me encontré
sola abajo con este hombre que tenía la
cara contra el suelo había sangre por
todas partes
[Música]
tenía una pierna completamente lesionada
con un gran charco de sangre
[Música]
puse la mano en el hongo y presione un
poco para ver si reaccionaba porque en
ese momento no había reaccionado para
nada se mueve un poco gruñó un poco
y
entonces recuerdo que le dije algo muy
particular
le dije pareces una buena persona vas a
pasar la noche con nosotros
[Música]
cuando volví a bajar me encontré con
véronique que volvía a subir le dije
sube al cuarto piso ahí está daniel
[Música]
un correo al mundo
cuando llegué abajo estaba todo
iluminado por la luz automática y pensé
que si los terroristas que estaban en la
calle veían la luz vendrían así que le
dije a más yo no podemos quedarnos aquí
tenemos que escondernos
supongo que mi vida ese árbol
creo que en ese momento él sintió que
estaba a salvo me agradeció en francés
con un fuerte acento estadounidense y me
dio las gracias aunque no había hecho
nada por él todavía
eres un ángel te quiero
en ese momento creo que se sintió muy
aliviado y entonces me dijo que me caso
[Música]
para mí lo más difícil ya estaba hecho
podíamos encerrarnos atrincherarnos
cerrar la puerta con llave
ah
en ese momento mi temor era que entraran
en el edificio intentamos llamar a los
bomberos a urgencias a llamamos a la
policía anotaron la dirección nuestros
nombres les dijimos que estábamos en el
pasaje a mel ott número 14 y nos dijeron
no sabemos si podemos llegar hasta
ustedes esperen
danielle estaba muy agitado agarro su
teléfono llamo busque un cargador porque
no tenía suficiente batería
el problema era que tenía ese vídeo y no
lograba enviar
cuando lo vi para mí era un periodista
de guerra tenía imágenes tendría que
enviársela a sus colegas lo recuerdo y
me dije pero este hombre no se da cuenta
de la vida que tiene y
él también estaba en estado de shock y
con mucha adrenalina no podía estarse
quieto iba de un lado a otro hablaba muy
muy alto recuerdo que le dije en un
momento habla más bajito o te doy un
golpe no despiertes a mi hijo no tiene
por qué ver esto
y por otro lado estaba matthew que yacía
inmóvil válido
- el aspecto en área daniel que el
aspecto de martillo que había vomitado
que la herida se veía bastante fea se
podía abrir el hueso en fin era fea
nuestra idea era hacerlo hablar nos
contó que trabajaba en google que era
estadounidense que el 11 de septiembre
había estado en nueva york
y pensé que estaba delirando y dije no
es posible no puede pasar por dos
atentados en su vida
[Música]
en algún momento alrededor de las 11 de
la noche empecé a sentirme débil me
estaba debilitando físicamente estaba
más lento y entonces pensé esto no es
bueno
instruyen existe recuerdo que me dijo es
pero no puedo morirme tengo que decirte
algo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
los que sea así cuando estaba tirado en
el suelo lo que me desesperaba era que
tres semanas antes me había casado con
sara
el theremin iztúris de todos los amigos
en los compañeros la familia habían
estado ahí
amigo él ya había ido y fue muy emotivo
como me decía pero como voy a hacer me
casé y me voy a morir
y mi gran preocupación era saber cuántos
litros de sangre tiene uno en el cuerpo
porque con la cantidad de sangre que
estaba perdiendo
si hubiera sabido que eran 6 litros
había entrado en pánico porque 6 litros
se pierden rápido
quise presionar mi pulgar y hacer un
punto de presión bajo su axila
[Música]
cimentó y cuando puse mis dos pulgares
recuerdo que bajo su brazo sentí que mis
dedos entraban en su herida por detrás
es una sensación que me quedó muy
grabado sentí la carne y el calor de la
sangre
[Música]
y
te dices a ti mismo que te vas a morir y
que hace uno antes de morir al contrario
de lo que dicen uno no ve su vida pasar
frente a sus ojos y ahí me digo más yo
está acabado en el estado en el que está
no va a sobrevivir
y esa noche mi hijo él y estaba cerca
del city bell viendo el partido de
fútbol entre francia e inglaterra
es siempre ha vivido en parís estado con
sus amigos y no hubiera podido estar en
el café de el bataclán viendo el partido
y
enseguida los ame y le dije no salgas
quédate en el café él me dijo que está
pasando le dije pasó algo muy complicado
en el bataclán no te muevas del café
quédate ahí
y me llamo muchas veces y le dije estoy
herido estoy esperando ayuda y me dijo
cata pasta
se
lo
diré
en un momento dado era justo la
medianoche llevábamos dos horas allá
arriba se produjo el asalto bueno lo
oímos las persianas estaban cerradas
pero no podíamos ver no vimos el ruido
las paredes temblaban
eran disparos el río de las calas mico
de todo ruido por todas partes
y verónica y este le estaban acurrucados
contra la pared aterrorizadas era
realmente terrorismo se podía ver lo que
era el terrorismo la definición del
terrorismo estábamos aterrorizados
ah
[Música]
como si
yo había sobrevivido a la entrada del
edificio no me iba a morir ahí sabíamos
que la policía estaba ahí se oían las
sirenas en las explosiones y luego en un
momento dado no se oía nada esperamos un
poco y luego abrí la ventana y vi un
cordón de policías entonces lo llamé
para ver me apuntaron hacia mí así que
levante las manos como un idiota y les
dije tenemos heridos aquí en el
apartamento
pero algunos entraron en el pasillo
yo estaba gritando en la escalera que
bajaba a pie para dejar que más yo
bajara por el ascensor para que lo
sacaran
con el torniquete puesto estaba sin
camisa y sangrando
llegué a mi piso al segundo piso
le dije estoy herido
y él pensaba que yo era un francotirador
o un terrorista que estaba huyendo
estaba en el tejado
y la
era totalmente absurdo
y
un gran pánico nadie sabía lo que estaba
pasando
y pico civil manifestase y policía
encubierto me dejó pasar
afortunadamente porque no sé lo que
habría pasado si me disparaban por una
confusión habría sido un gran error
me dije todo está saliendo mal pero no
fue así fue un milagro
en ese momento salí del infierno
mi destino sano me pertenecía en cierto
modo
estaba en manos de los medios solo me
decían que tenían todos los nervios
quemados que se sentía como una
explosión en el brazo
[Música]
y entonces cuando estaba un poco más
despierto saliendo de la anestesia me
pregunté qué habrá pasado con más no
tenía ninguna noticia no sabía en
absoluto que le había pasado
[Música]
por cosas del destino él estaba a dos
habitaciones de la mía estábamos al lado
y nos volvimos a encontrar
[Música]
lo que la vistió en parís concilio
fui a verlo porque podía caminar a él
también lo habían operado así que
hablamos un poco no nos conocíamos me
contó cómo había salido de la sala de
conciertos tenía un montón de gente
encima sobre él estaba herido
e
intentaba salir y en su cabeza pensaba
que no podía caminar pero sobre todo
tenía mucha gente encima
de la puerta de emergencia tenía un
pequeño refuerzo de donde se pudo
agarrar metió los dedos obviamente
empujado por la fuerza de la
desesperación apartó a los tipos que
estaban encima de él se desgarró todos
los músculos de la espalda de tanto que
jaló y se las arregló para salir de
audiencias extenso
y
se arrastró sobre la acera de enfrente
para no estar entre la multitud y acabó
donde yo lo encontré
el círculo se había cerrado pero de
hecho no se había cerrado porque empezó
otra cosa que a mí se me escapaba la
parte mediática
filas son berduc
estaba fuera de control en ese frenesí
mediático todos los televisores y
periódicos del mundo hablaban de lo
sucedido eso provocó una cadena de
eventos muy difícil de manejar
yo siempre había trabajado en la sombra
y en ese momento las luces estaban sobre
mí con el circo mediático
[Música]
me dije de todos modos las imágenes
servirán como prueba o tal vez no en
cualquier caso algo pasa y como
periodista uno de testimoniales
las redes sociales los canales de
noticias la brisa y esta inmediatez todo
es muy violento llegaron las teorías de
conspiración con los insultos y sus
[Música]
incluso al día siguiente intentaron
demostrar que todas las imágenes eran
falsas
[Música]
también estaba la pregunta de si esas
imágenes debían difundirse o no
creo que sí porque son un testimonio son
los hechos
son imágenes duras pero en una realidad
que no se podía negar la minera la
prueba con imágenes porque los
testimonios son frágiles si no hubiera
tenido las imágenes habría contado como
la gente caía una tras otra bajo las
balas que había una mujer embarazada
colgada de la ventana a punto de caerse
el testimonio habría sido ligeramente
cuestionado las imágenes hablan por sí
mismas aunque haya habido divagaciones
en torno a este vídeo la realidad de los
hechos como se dice los hechos son
tercos eso es lo que ocurrió
pues este experimento no me victimizaba
es decir no me consideraba una vez
había salido milagrosamente de todo eso
y bastante bien así que cuanto mejor
continúe con mi vida
en mi vida desde los 20 hasta los 62
estaba aquí así que era muy importante
estaba llena de recuerdos de recuerdos
muy buenos recuerdos muy crueles
recuerdos muy duros
para mí era una forma de resistencia es
decir todo el mundo me preguntaba no te
vas a mudar si yo decía no si me mudaré
ganarían ellos es decir porque iba a
huir de un lugar que era mío en el que
había invertido que había construido eso
significaría que ellos ganarían aunque
yo tenía ese miedo de que vinieran a
matarme en mi casa
el nuevo no más que miedo que surgía a
menudo era que su abriera la puerta de
mi casa y que hubiera una asesina y me
matará ese pensamiento me acompaña
durante mucho tiempo
si te difícil
fue difícil fue por todo lo que había
vivido durante esa noche desde el vecino
que pensaba que había un asesino que iba
a entrar en el pasillo y dispararnos
[Música]
lavalle
me imagino que eso me afectó estaba ese
trauma que ya no existe pero que era me
van a matar
[Música]
el inglés hizo un mueble
todos mis nervios están quemados no
siento los medios que duele me indica
cómo se pincharán permanentemente con
miles de agujas en ambos dedos y los
músculos están atrofiando
es molesto antes me gustaba tocar
guitarra ya no puedo hacerlo
[Música]
y mi vida cambió el 13 de noviembre
porque ocurrió un hecho fundamental
[Música]
y si me voy de aquí no por el 13 de
noviembre el 13 de noviembre es parte de
mi apartamento la tragedia también hubo
grandes alegrías
[Música]
en la vida y todo el mundo vive con sus
altibajos y sus cosas bellas y menos
bellas
[Música]
y fue vivida hasta los 20 años de
adolescente después mi vida adulta y
luego una tercera vida a los 60 años
[Música]
y volvía a cazar tengo un hijo qué
suerte tengo
ya digo metí al draw man por supuesto
pero qué suerte
me las arreglo bien
[Música]
s pienso en mi viaje a jerusalén
y
sólo seguirá costumbre de dejar una nota
con mi número de celular
no
si dios existe y llamará me había dicho
claro que nunca me llamo pero me gusta
pensar que el 13 de noviembre de 2015 a
las 10 de la noche unos minutos cuando
la muerte me rozó por fin me contestó
[Música]
no
el frío
[Música]
frente
as
[Música]
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de reporteros recuerde que puede
ingresar a nuestra página web más 24
punto com para ver esta emisión y las
anteriores hasta la próxima semana